really well with us now as the director
John s Baird
director of stan and Ollie
congratulations on your three BAFTA
nomination system very much delighted
yeah I'm still a bit shocked to be fair
somebody woke me up yesterday morning at
7:37 we've got three we've got three I
said we've got three what so no it was
it was a it was a great thing it was the
first time I've been nominated as well
so I'm really gonna savor the moment on
the night yeah and it's interesting
because it's nominated alongside another
biopic Bohemian Rhapsody that tells the
full story of Queen in their heyday but
you've chosen a section of Lauren
Hardy's history
that's not very well known it's after
their their big heyday it's when they're
sort of not on their uppers but they see
themselves as fading stars and wonder if
anybody will watch them anymore yeah we
decided that it'd be more interesting to
tell a story when they when they were
facing a lot of challenges you know when
you try to do a movie you look for
conflict you look for things that
challenge the characters and that's part
of their life they were less popular you
know up and Costello were really the the
double act who taken over at that point
and stan and Ollie were were the there
was an ill health they weren't real
financial difficulties because we're
very poor at the end of there at the end
of the careers because they didn't have
rights to any other films you know the
studio the studio contracts were were
not very favorable to these payer and
they're the head of the studio start
their contracts six months apart so they
never had any negotiating power either
so they don't face a lot of challenges
and we thought therefore that would make
a forward interest in film you know more
drama more conflict and more comedy that
comes from that as well I suspect this
is part of the reason why what there
will be a bittersweet element to this
film and Minister we're told that you
know we Scott so obviously very very
unemotional characters but you you cried
on on first reading the script I did and
I get sent a lot of scripts you know
potential so I to making the potential
films and this was the first time I'd
ever cried on a read and I thought well
if it can make me cry on page it's
actually a huge potential for what it
can do for an audience you know and and
that's why I really wanted to get into
it you know
Laurel and Hardy since I was eight years
old there's a photograph of me as an
eight year old kid dressed the Stan
Laurel at their school fancy dress party
and a friend of mine is Oliver Hardy so
it goes back a long way the love affair
for myself with these two guys but
there's an emotional tail and there are
laughs and they are but it's not a note
comedy it's a drama it's a love story
with comedic elements you talk to me
about the double act of Coogan and Riley
because they went to great lengths to
mimic and perfect the the comedic moves
of Lauren Hardy which of cause of so
world famous yeah well there were our
first choices for the rules it was a
very limited list of who we thought
could play these two characters and
Steve was you know Stan was from England
Steve's from England and the same height
was born in the same region all he was a
you know an American and John's assim so
I hate and so the physicality was there
but we also needed great dramatic actors
and great comedic actors as well and
their list when you're looking for that
many things in an octa the list is very
very short and they took a little bit of
persuading because they were playing
their heroes and it was so much like
Oneg so iconic and so much
responsibility as well to you know to do
it right so what we decided to do was it
you know it wasn't a massive budget film
and we decided to spend a lot of our
resources in rehearsals and and given
them time to perfect the routines like
the dance at the beginning and all the
sort of comedic routines that they do so
we invested a lot and in that period
year themselves because they were thrown
together when they as a pairing much
like steve coogan
yeah exactly the same Hal Roach who was
the head of the studio picked out Laurel
and Hardy separately put them together
and said write YouTube before they
create an arc and Stan wrote all the
material that they did 107 films and
Stan wrote them all but Steve and John
had to get you know each other within
four weeks so it was a very sort of
intense period to get that because
didn't know each other before so I can I
was the coverage of for them threw them
together and and they've done the you
know they've done these these men you
know so much good service
and the biggest compliment we've had so
far in the film was from Stan's great
granddaughter Cassidy cook who came to
see the film at the premiere and she
said I forgot I was watching actors I
thought I was watching my
great-grandfather on the screen it was
an incredible thing to hear yeah that is
a great compliment and it's also getting
rave reviews from critics as well who we
know are hard to please and thank you
very much John s Baird director of stan
and Ollie which is out in cinemas
tomorrow tomorrow yes of brilliant
really looking forward to see that and
nominated for three-bath ders as well